there is a very sexually charged scene
in the film but the deli meats don't
have any actual penis or vagina right
one there's a pita bread without scrotum
it's not really well they kind of that
was something we kind of played with is
like how far can we push this stuff
right and so we submitted it and we at
first got an nc-17 rating back right our
fear was that it would then create this
like big negotiation process where we
ultimately had to like butcher the
[ __ ] thing you know right did they
surprise you by allowing things to go
through that you didn't think would get
passed honestly in all gone movie it all
honesty yes like we probably added six
things into the orgy that we were like
okay these are like our sacrificial
lambs orgy and they are the chips that
we're willing to lose had we lost like
an eighth of one of them yeah like there
is a pita bread and you see his ball
sack in the end orgy and it had hair on
it right and they asked we remove the
hair from the pita bread ball sack fine
all right we'll do it exactly so we
digitally shaved the pita breads ball
sack and then removed the hair for bits